hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't starve
together with Bob hi Bob hi everybody hi
so we are in a new world of don't
starving they've made a lot of changes
it's now in full release and we get to
go do stuff apparently and so we're
gonna show me where when I go off screen
for you does it show you a little thing
pointing at where I am yeah okay
sorry I had to pick up seeds that's so
helpful I feel like when we played
before it was like alright now go go
right go straight right and I'm no no
I'm down from you or I feel like there
was a lot of that situation there was oh
my god I chopped so fast oh my god also
make tree gods I've discovered what the
terrible secret is the lumberjack has a
lovely axe and a terrible secret what's
that I'm not gonna tell you because I
feel like it's better I feel like it's
better if we just leave this as it is
he's gone baby did you uh did you hear
anything he just make like orgasm sound
after he chop the tree down
but do you uh can you can you hear
anyone talking to you no okay good yeah
that's good yeah nothing no one's
talking to me either well it's lost
we're in the same as on the same page
it's fine
hell yeah man it's really already gonna
be nice I'm it's really already gonna be
like that apparently good god oh no it's
just evening we're fine on evening but I
do need to make a campfire yeah well we
need stones for that right wait I can
just make like a regular campfire yeah I
got bad news um apparently my wood meter
is going down you're you're sad when you
destroy wood no just I don't know what
the wood meter is it's just a meter of
wood and it he's going down can you can
you eat wood oh my god I can eat wood
holy [ __ ]
I literally I eat wood hey there's bees
over here let's not do that
I eat wood what do whatever you gotta do
Ben I just okay
the meter goes down when I chop wood but
it goes back up when I eat wood so it's
kind of like I chop faster but also I
have to eat some of this I'm sorry it's
just the way life goes
but the wood definitely doesn't raise my
hunger that's that's one thing wood
doesn't do oh that's useful all of this
is horrifically on the up you need to
eat that does not make you less hungry
yeah exactly isn't this great oh and
also my secret is my axe is talking to
me wow really
my axe is encouraging me to kill people
just trees through the trees the trees
the trees if your mortal enemy well but
it's it's in don't starve talking right
so it's like I got a blow dart now I'm a
blow I'm gonna blow that come on dammit
the burn I was gonna wait don't move oh
hey hey I know where we should set up
camp right here I see bushes I see
rabbit holes nice yep and I should craft
some traps hell yeah oh hell yeah
okay so we need hell yeah I need some
grass to be able to make a meat dress
don't worry all my I really quit my
accents like you came back for me
there's a Piketty goo over here a
peggotty goo there's a bunch of pig
heads I know there's a touchstone what
do those do at uh I don't know touch it
that's probably a good thing touch it hi
now I'm gonna wait I think we should
wait until we at least have a little bit
of serenity and success before we go
touching things come on man touch it
there's a thing there's a thing brewing
around over here making like ground hog
tunnels I think we should stand the
yellow part I think that's our thing
yeah there's plenty of berry bushes
there's burros we got a lot of resources
here it's a good starting point so that
people won't
to be man yeah people won't be
incredibly mad at us when we eventually
fail oh it's night oh please make the
fire I'm gonna make a fire I'm gonna
make a fire oh why am I not making the
fire hey hey hey
perfect timing huh welcome to the high
yeah hi how's it going
ah sorry about killing your twin sister
apparently it's all good is it oh wow
you're very forgiving I'm pretty fine
it's fine
how do you make a torch um you need oh
yeah George yeah also set some gravity
trap ities okay you do that also good
news uh I never run out of ax my axe is
unbreakable
Wow really yeah that's nice my axe just
told me to chop some trees I got a go
dude I gotta go set the traps where I
told you to girl lady person girl girl
why you [ __ ] why you [ __ ] my [ __ ]
up let's see maybe we need to come what
calm down Oh what's happened Jaime I'm
gonna see what happens when my my wheel
oh what a sidle rage yeah my my axe is
starting to get worried you might want
to eat a log it just told me that and
I'm like well that doesn't seem like a
logical thing to do slow down I'm
worried about you what is happening to
my I don't want to die but I want to be
near you to witness what yeah okay it's
only gonna be a few more trees trust me
cover your beaver [ __ ]
I could eat I could eat oh my god
yes my hunger meter got replaced that's
amazing
this is amazing is this permanent I
[ __ ] hope now you drop your axe I got
like you're welcome you're welcome
you're welcome welcome
pick up Lucy the axe I wonder if you
pick up Lucy have you I couldn't I
couldn't no I walked over there there
was no option to do anything your
character was just like I know better
than this this is horrifying
okay I took a hit to my sanity but when
I was eating as a beaver it did fill up
my hunger or did it maybe it didn't
maybe I ate I captured a bunny bunny or
another bunny bunny good I'm we're gonna
get more food here we're gonna get build
a nice base here and then we're gonna be
good right
oh wow birch trees they give birch nuts
and you can eat them oh that's Andy you
just like shake them I don't know I've
only charged I've only tried chopping
them can you literally I only know how
to chop I mean if you if you need
someone to chop wood just you know it's
just it's my it's my worldview it's what
I do I did my dad chopped I job my mom
was on the show chopped I mean I can't
do nothing but chopped I feel like I
feel like those are linguistically
related but not actually related okay
it's a joke
alright now I I'm gonna touch this
touchstone oh good okay I was wondering
how soon it would be before we lost
oh no apparently doesn't you can't touch
it it won't let you touch it I really
want some like gold that's what I want
yeah oh there's something in your trap
here I'm gonna reset your triumphs duper
hungry we should cook up some of these
they're rabbits that I got and heat them
up heat him up and stuff
and we can set the dang trip there we go
okay where was camp anywhere on this
yellow part I'm coming back toward to
the left of I picked up the ashes it was
like right here um if we had more stone
I could make it more permanent one but
so now this will do cabo ski and I'm
gonna murder this rattle plant that guy
yeah yeah now
okay I'm gonna cook these birch nuts can
you move like to the side of no I'm
cooking you dinner I cook I also have
rabbit morsels that I need to cook I'm
gonna give you all of my birch nuts Oh
give me your nuts
just take my nuts go Oh God
you like those nuts I'm gonna give you
some of my meats thanks man
I'm gonna feed you my meat almost as
good as these logs anyway you didn't see
but I ate a log I put some logs on this
fire I'm out of I'm out of grassy grass
good grass already all right well let's
see we got a lot of time till actual
night so you can go out and do stuff I'm
gonna go south ish see if I can find
something down there
we need to find a rocks gold you're
correct
oh it's to the south nope no rocks it
just the rocky yeah South okay
definitely
there was nothing north so that's good
okay so I found a gold vein I just made
one cuz I'm a pro at this game we've
been playing this long enough that I
know exactly what I'm doing okay
this is cool lying on the ground here
why is there the gold just lying on the
ground it by the way I'm in a graveyard
but there's gold lying on the ground
well you should definitely take people
I've been taking it yeah non-stop yeah
no no question oh yeah take that [ __ ]
it's like free money why wouldn't I
geez what am i stupid no I'm taking it
what am i an imbecile no yeah thanks for
agreeing with me man I'm definitely a
smart man you are okay I've got seven
gold so far and I'm gonna come back
about now cuz it's about Jersey sciency
GU will I need one gold and some locks
did you get any rocks oh hell yeah you
know I got rocks oh I know you got the
rocks you know I always got rocks from
my man man I got the best rocks you ask
anyone around town who's got the best
rocks me my player mark that guy yeah
they don't say me episode that wouldn't
be me that's the best rocks me wait no
dude no no I'm like who else has the
best rocks
damn I suck at placing these traps oh my
god there's so many so many berry bushes
there's like five berry bushes right
here trip if you could just go over the
hole thank you
holy [ __ ] I got time I'm coming back did
I is there any fuel left in the thing I
did know I don't know I'm not there I'm
not there either
I don't see your icon on the mini-map
it's barely there it's almost not there
but I see you whoosh whoosh whoosh
whoosh oh that's a fire that's a sweet
fire I've got I'm gonna put this on the
ground
oh that's smoldering that's oh oh oh god
oh oh hello oh is this how we trade
okay.you I don't know it's like
creepiest song ever here you can take my
berries cuz I've got a good store of
them well I'm gonna pick up these gold
nuggets and I thank your stone you can
logs and rocks yes and logs logs do I
got logs oh yeah oh yeah we wanna do we
want to permanently science it up here
hell yeah
there's a good location down south is
rock up north there's more stuff hell
yeah
sighs yeah [ __ ] yeah we can
continue this in the next episode
[ __ ] I shouldn't have started
eating at our prices bad time - mmm good
don't so thank you everybody so much for
watching we're gonna play a few more
episodes of don't starve and this time
we're gonna do actually good because we
know what we're doing and we're not
gonna fail we've never actually been
able to play this game right in the
entire time we played this so we've
never actually failed
oh god will you pay up too many times
but now we're super good mm-hmm but
thank you guys everybody so much for
watching and as always we'll see
[Music]
ever happen to me salmonella